yeah hello welcome to this broadcast I
hope this is working fine i have to
adjust a little bit to be honest here by
set up after my move some things a
little bit different yeah like the
positioning of my screens and things
like that low thanks but yeah human
beings are creatures of habit and every
change is kind of kind of not so easy
okay I hope you are all all right yeah
welcome to all the regulars here in the
in the chat ya see many familiar names
but let's get going I want to play some
games and going to shoot for skiing 5
million shares playing with Vic like wow
I haven't played this guy for a long
time I have never played it with the
chairs explained account but he's a
strong player isn't that cute orly keit
early yet sir GM from Norway ok deadly
let's see what we get Spanish opening
and yeah I'm going for four they 6 here
for mainline stuff yep the 63 lon so
would this vc3 ok playable of course I'm
just going to cancel him and now we are
the question is do I want to still play
a chick oriental style set up or not a
forum hmm you don't see that too often
in this kind of situation hmm often
Bishop d7 is a questionable move after
d3 but i think he is actually ok s he s
played c3 so we'll see him
I have looked a bit I studied the brea
variation a little bit recently so maybe
I get some night p8 down my 97 in later
yeah I see them um broadcast seems to go
well I'm trying to do this maneuver now
I see that the I've got some background
noise in the picture but this is
something that will resolve itself when
I change the light bulbs in the ceiling
yeah it's kind of funny sometimes the
little things that yeah that that don't
work out as they as they were planned
it's quite funny i got and moved with
all the light bulbs or the lighting from
our place to the new one but the
somewhat brighter lamps that i had in my
office to have a better lighting for the
videos they are now in some other room
and i I've got the less powerful
lighting no amor offers I have to just
change the light bulbs there I only
noticed this when when the video setup
here was done today and I didn't yet
managed to get to change this it's
something that I will do for next time I
carry I go King go see 5 i'm happy to do
that oh wow really that looks nice
actually he doesn't have a comfortable
way of defending you for now i
understand that he felt that night
before as an idea and so on but isn't he
fought just week now yeah this is the
move that you're not so happy with I
guess okay 93 and that doesn't look too
great yes not before word is centrally
an issue I think I'm I want to
get in night h5 possibly Bishop jeha but
night h5 he will probably play Knight f3
back okay maybe just play some
strengthening moves IKS bishop you one
yeah that's a good move trying to cover
d3 you know i mean i don't think i have
a problem here but it was a good
regrouping f4 are you serious what that
is possible that's cool okay I'll take
this I don't believe this at all not at
all but let's not get too excited him
it's a question in the chat if I can
recommend a book about the rock ozan
yeah there is there is the book about
the recording this is the book scored
there goes in complex by think by zip a
pass key said basking yeah russian
author i think it's Barsky my mother was
taken it's a pretty substantial book
pretty good book okay so what am i doing
him i would just here take that bishop I
didn't want to take and possibly rookie
five hook takes age five and f4 was a
very questionable move I guess
things are so kind of messy it's not
like I'm winning easily but it's some
something that objectively should be
pretty bad yeah don't really see what
he's doing now him pieces don't do much
but he's a dangerous tactical player I'm
aware of that okay so maybe just grab
stuff check cake d 5 take your fire
office there's something wrong with that
move I don't see it I'm taking this yeah
it is babis key right there goes in book
yeah yeah i mean this book is sam is
still the standard kind of the book
about it it has some it's a couple of
years old by now but it's still the 12
to start with let's say maybe i can
actually take play Bishop before I play
Bishop if I know we cannot do that okay
we'll see it's still the book to to get
to start with the whole opening if you
are interested in it and probably as it
is such a popular line nowadays it makes
quite some sense to to study yourself
analyze a little bit yourself there are
so many developments with all the top
level games being played so make sense
to get VP be up to date with all this
okay I'm about this game I wonder yeah i
think i'll just go back here
yeah thnkx wait I'm happy to have the
live stream going right after my move
that there wasn't any issues with the
internet or anything like that it was
all working rather oh it's all working
rather smoothly and that was something
that i feared a little bit that there
would be some technical problem over
nothing they installed my internet
chatting on on the Friday a couple of
days ago and everything worked basically
out of the box no no problems no no
nothing it just worked ok so I returned
one pawn to coordinate my position a
little bit a little better time morning
still not completely easy task to win
especially not with no time even though
it looks pretty good rookie seven I
think is what I'm going to play next
unless he is somehow preventing it which
I don't see how how that might work ok
ok f at ETA will take the five you
that's not so great Queenie form I can
also take c3 here that looks wrong let's
go here check
step any big idea I don't see it really
looks like I've got good control not
sure why I played h5 to be honest here
this is a good one useful move check it
didn't make much sense check check check
check check white forehead yeah on a
time that was good look happy yo okay so
I'm I want to see if there's something
in the chat what do I think about the
tracks la gambit hmm whoo well it
attracts them the tracks led gambit
recently got mentioned it just to make
sure i'm going to show you what what is
it what the track is actually this is
the trucks my gambit I'm sorry obviously
not yeah it is right actually this is a
truck slowed wear white can take on f7
in two ways it's a very crazy opening
something something like this is
happening it actually recently got
mentioned um in a book that was
published about the e 45 black rubber
[ __ ] bunny cause the tailless and he
actually mentioned that you think that
this is a decent opening which is kind
of funny because he's a good tuition so
maybe there's something to it but it's
it's very very difficult to
to assess its it's a super-sharp
technically there's a question by
Victoria cow what to do um against the
500 points higher rated player play a
normal game or play something and
something else I just say play a normal
game 500 points is is a pretty big
difference so usually um yeah you you
don't stand a chance I mean if you
transfer that if you say 500 points
higher than me and I would place there
wouldn't be a human being that I could
play so it's a huge it's huge difference
and play your normal game play what
you're good at what you feel good about
and this is some I think what you should
do ok um cat this line I've simply
forgot I always forget what I need to do
here at 95 there is some night a five
before business but is it here on now
okay yeah I can go before I'm pretty
sure about that yeah d for this Bishop
f3m some funny ideas takes knight c6 is
pretty good for black anyway i think as
i get d 4 and so on yeah this is
interesting now if i take yes to take
with the pawn as Queen takes b3 is
losing the bishop yeah 500 more than be
that would be cards never 536 2930 or
something that's not that's not not
existing simply okay and I was thinking
night h5 but he might have f4 it looks
kind of funky that looks kind of funky
with knives on a hip at age five
question by John Smith what did I do
with my students when you move to the
new place well I mean they're basically
almost all of them are online so there
is no no big issue there and I'm it's
not that I have yeah that I am I moved
to a different continent or anything I
just moved like like 10 15 miles or
something 15 miles from our old place so
it's not a not a big issue so what to do
here i think i'll put the same yeah it
looks good I need a rook I need to look
somewhere do I get a look I can take
three pawn takes but i have no i just
actually funky maybe i can get rook big
one i think i have to cast me anyway so
let's castle and go from here hmm
can also just play King age 8 and f5
maybe this is the thing
okay I guess night x there's a question
if I played 100 games with cards and
what score I might get who and not many
points not quite sure what the
mathematical expectation is what the
expected score is it's not much anyway
it's not much anyway
rugby to West idea if he allows that
would be fantastic I don't expect this
to happen though okay what looks tricky
now I mean not saying I'm winning but
okay have too many what's it used to
play some Queen f1 or something like
that yeah and now do I have a win night
h3r up [ __ ] to just about the fence I
just back here right I maybe I should
have taken the 96 not sure
whose highest rated player that ever
played over the board the highest rated
player i think that i played over the
board was probably mikuni on in 2014 he
was 26 74 or something at the time I
have played a couple of two thousand six
hundred plus some GM's ok Queen left you
I can just take F to hear think I'll do
that but I have played a couple of I've
played some players that I think they
were actually better players but they
might have had a lower rating at the
time i played Luce for example 2 times
and he was a top 10 player at his best
also I lost those games pretty pretty
pretty clearly ma'am without I mean I
tried my best but you cannot say I put
up a big resistance there I came I tried
to double on the second drink yeah
pledged a trend really last week
actually and lost pretty badly i will
feature that game on my channel at some
point that's a question I modern
grandmasters better than then classical
players like glass computer how would
ronnian fare against luscombe and so on
yeah this is always a very difficult
thing to say um it's a difficult thing
to say an older autumn kind of
discussion I think that reside that yeah
he cannot really defending a soupy to I
think that the the modern players are
quite quite a bit stronger there were
parts I mean from from those old games
if you look at games Bible askah or
elocon or couple Blanco starring and
there are many many very strong games
they also had pretty bad games so the
the really good ones they look like the
dead like they're on the on a modern
modern kind of level but you sometimes
see games where you really wonder what
they were thinking it's a it's a pretty
big difference I think that the the best
things that they played back then the
best games they're really on
exceptionally high standard but there
are also some pretty awful games where
you see that they didn't have the the
knowledge of nowadays of course this is
not meaning that there were stupid or
bad or whatever it's just the simple
case that we benefit from all the
knowledge that they have fun that they
have let's say yeah inherited to us if
you want um Casey 5am who can take can
close the position both is interesting I
think I'll close it and was a question
who's the weakest player that I lost
against and drew again since becoming an
IM Oh interesting I lost I lost the game
like two or three years ago against
someone rated 2,100 in a local in a
local event in a in a cup match and only
recently ended Joe and I drew a drew a
game against the play with about 1950 in
the tournament last year in that case
however have to say that I mean the game
that I lost i just lost him and it was a
kind of complete it was a unclear
complicated game and i just made a made
a terrible mistake and he won fair and
square the game against 1950 player was
actually
pretty complicated full full game but it
was to find a round of an event that had
already had one and them all so we are
we are friends so I mean I just said
okay let's let's make it draw and and
let's go have some some nice dinner or
something that was probably a little bit
worse in that position though and I mean
I probably would have played if I had a
great position but it was kind of
unclear and the draw was ok so what
about this I would like to if possible
get this night to e3 now control age 50
to control age 5 + f5 yeah ideally and
this looks like it's it's it's going to
be going to be possible um ok let's open
this up we have a keyword rumen Stein in
the chat and he also was a fantastic
player old if you look at Rubinstein for
example this is a very nice an
interesting a case from those look at an
old older play a classical player if you
look at Rubenstein's best endgames yeah
he played fantastically well in in rook
endings or in positions where he had a
very clear strategic idea but he had
also some games where he had to
calculate a lot where it was unclear
where as murky and in those games he did
not play particularly well we have to be
honest there yeah so there's a big
difference he had extremely good games
and then some in some kind of position
types as I said endings and dumb and
strategically focused games but some
other not so much yeah I'm a big fan of
Rubenstein don't get me wrong with it
just we have to UM we have to like tell
it like it was or like it is
he was strong in many regards but not in
all types of in all phases of the game
and this is also a pretty big difference
to modern chess that the modern players
are usually they have their strengths
and weaknesses but the week sites are
not as pronounced as it happened or as
it was with them the players of old okay
so what about this it really looks like
there should be some kind of some kind
of decisive strike I'm thinking about
g3i but i think i should just should i
should just do this right it's just a
good position here should switch off my
mobile yeah just go to g3 to as a
question anyone got any ideas how to
explain show to 12 to 15 year olds just
beginners why chest is so great mmm yeah
maybe it's not so easy actually because
to appreciate the beauty of the game it
it's almost done yeah you need to
understand a little bit what's going on
yeah other than what what mrs. Garcia is
saying is pretty pretty true get them
some weak opponents so that they can win
games it the the this is this is there
some truth to that of course okay i
wonder if i go here i really don't know
i just play by just play but yeah here
maybe it's not such a great idea
actually
a [ __ ] hmm ah too lazy check out to
this clip d31 we wanna keep it keep it
simple method if it takes you 30 go if I
497 double check yeah of course the
someone mentioned that ronnian also
played a not so great game in the in the
Bundesliga they all have their good and
bad days that suits it's certainly true
but check if you look at it's not
comparable to what what the classical
players what they did actually wanted to
go up the one but it doesn't matter that
much ok let's go here for the deep on
time morning
so would you win this the quickest
possible way Bishop g4 I guess try to
take up six and then promote handle to
Peter Finley yeah he says the longtime
fan of my channel and now can catch a
live broadcast yeah welcome black
resigns well I'm having a good good run
here pretty happy with this okay let's
see let's go for gain start in game not
Larson yeah that's easy lossless
unfortunately dead now for a couple of
years okay I'll go for you for I play
something aggressive yeah let's play the
Kings gambit I've got week rest for
stuff like that and why not I mean it's
not particularly great but why not here
and down playa Kings gambit how does
that work there should be five or Bishop
c4 I don't know I kept playing the check
k castles blunder so let's go deform
he's playing them the so-called modern
defense to the Kings gambit this is
something that i also have recommended
in a video of mine some time ago I think
that is a very sensible approach for
black kind of a no-nonsense strategy
just develop and to enjoy healthy
position it's not one of the super crazy
lines that you sometimes have in the
King's gambit but this is blacks choice
I mean he went from solid plane
and what was wrong with twitch I'm not
sure I mean that there was something
wrong with it in particular it's just
that streaming on YouTube has some
advantages with which one thing that is
kind of really helpful is that that it
get all gets automatically archived in
to YouTube it's quite that it's a nice
feature and it's easier to to reach
people that data on YouTube by just
streaming on youtube so it makes quite a
lot of sense to do it okay I want to get
the Queen out of that pin I'm not sure
about this position that might not be so
bad for what what now where those pawns
are rather annoying I think I'll regroup
here night to be five Bishop to c4 just
I mean this is not a minister Kings
gambit but it's still a rather it's a
normalish kind of position where it's
not totally irrational that's what I'm
trying to say so we can think about week
squares like b5 Bishop to c4 is also and
said making quite some sense
by the way if any of you i'm watching
the stream now is a member of the the
chest publishing forum me this WWE chest
pop calm and there's a forum mostly
about chess books if some of you are
members of that and happen to like my
book there's currently a book of the
year contest where my book is one of the
nominated works so if you I remember
there please please step by and vote for
my book there is no big reward or
anything it just just for owner Sam so I
had to take only for I think which is
kind of sad but i hope i get some kind
of compensation in terms of playing in
terms of now in the shape of playing
some g5 I really had no big alternative
I think I had to take ok d5 this watch
95 I think I'll just go and go here
taking one of three it's not a big issue
here takes takes takes on our three
years not a big issue so I want to try
to play on the farm and no i did not
have a look at the chess herbal or chest
able i'm not quite sure about the
pronunciation i did not have a look yet
simply had no time at all
in the last couple of days I had to yeah
look at things like I don't know having
a working kitchen on things like that I
had didn't look at chess websites much
and my my kitchen is working i can
actually cook things and so on which was
not that easy
okay i was i was the ship t5 was more of
a problem now no d5 just looks good I
mean where is he going with us annoyed
ok so now it's their tactic it looks
suspicious it really does I don't see a
tactic though yes he wants to go night
f5 I think it looks like there should be
something when I don't see it ok I go
see for ok
hmm i wonder if i should transfer the
knight to c6 i'm not sure that it helps
i'll do that there is a question do I
think that Maria mu Z took has a shot at
the woman's world championship match
against we found I give her a chance of
like twenty percent in a match maybe
it's not like impossible that she can do
something but she's a pretty pretty big
pretty big underdog in that who you find
it simply very very strong check yeah
maybe let's go here for Queenie 8 196
maybe I'll look yet for that matter um
okay let's see the best system for white
against the Kings Indian defense there
is no one best system the Kings Indian
is a somewhat vulnerable opening anyway
and why should pick one system and and
study it thoroughly should get should
get a decent decent position there most
of the time Wow can I start very tricky
in this position here and now how to
tell 95 is good him
yeah that looks like some threats are
going on and I don't see what he is
threatening 97 oh no no I my Queens I
let's not forget about that instead
something better than trading trading
trading should win but a shank time hmm
and it's not an easy one really isn't
check I've checked be cautious not to
run into some kind of funky self made
him to be could happen it's no matter I
have no time f absolutely no time check
our position should win but sits now no
I'm reasonably sure that I can win this
check
black forfeits on time yeah I sped up at
the end okay so i didn't watch the chat
at all yeah i'll check that check that
side that chess abled side or chest pain
started but not sure if i would want to
publish some opening content on our side
it depends a little bit on their
business model simply okay so against
damn jen or 4 i've got a news oh I've
got a really good good result down the
session I really want i want to sleep
did I lose the game yet nope four out of
four that's pretty good check okay so
let's see I can get to the good old whom
the mainline rookie one can all many
many possible news I could be six it's
not mandatory but one of the possible
moves against rupee 1g3
that's a somewhat uncommon way to plan
yeah I think I'll go for the pin here
actually I want to get an f5 I wonder
how to do it here and I want to keep the
known f6 for a moment because we should
be towards to move on to unpin but
that's not so easy to do as far as
hanging so I have a couple of useful
moves no I have not thought about a
tournament in the summer
there's a question does someone know how
to coordinate your pieces this is skill
you get while just playing as a result
of a good opening or is there something
else and difficult question to answer in
there in a simple sentence and a lot of
it is about knowing what what happens in
certain middle game types I like in a
certain kind of position one one
particular piece placement is kind of
normal on on unusual also it is this
comes from studying studying games of
this of the sad middle games and simply
getting experience and knowledge about
about those typical structures okay I'm
do echo f4 here or what not taking us
actually good
I wonder i can call g5 here in this
position so that he has to go back I
wonder f4 as a move I should just
prevent it or not I think I'll prevent
there for him hmm good Muslim good move
how to play and probably neither 16 h 3
queen age 27 th three so let's go here
and f-14 age 3 is interesting takes
naija 40 a fall it's kind of a luxury
surprising that white can afford such a
move i was thinking at least write a
five or I do I have something better
here this also lays got 21 okay let's do
that and my favorite type of middle game
position to play yeah I don't know this
kind of position that we have here for
example is something that I really enjoy
enjoy playing it's a check has some
smaller strategic kind of thing and
require some some some kind of planning
or what but pieces to keep your pieces
to trade and it is not so much about I'm
calculating concrete lines which is
somewhat
it's not my forte so I rather have this
kind of position then some some wild
slugfests or whatever okay an
interesting position i'm somewhat down
on the clock and i didn't get as much as
i was hoping to get when it is not bad
here was not a bad a bad position would
like to get to a minor piece ending
where i can possibly play against to be
pawns there should be three ninety four
here and I thing is he just covers it
and then it's not quite clear what this
has accomplished so okay that was the
idea okay maybe now have to force him
okay okay let's just five to be seven
look that sets it should be okay for him
really this pollution wonder what my
mistake was I really thought I should
get some kind of a slight advantage
there after whites someone we had me
nervous but I didn't didn't get it right
uh-huh I keep a woman sign in the
channel announcer stated that his
birthday in two weeks so there may be
some surprises in store for us okay kind
of curious so what is he going for you
maybe 85 g for so i can let's see if i
can get this in seems i might be able to
do so ok
aha very interesting no I cannot take
this is hanging hmm hi morning check a
baby chick here hmm I guess got King b3
also rather than it can take actually
okay takes on b5 i can i can actually
capture because of the four points III
but I'm not sure that I'm threatening
much check and I could have to i do know
i can take actually
now that could be five no
white foreheads on Callie yeah five out
of five that was good okie dokie one
more game will I be undefeated in this
session they put the game started
playing G Bianchi have I don't have a
good score and sim one draw one loss
let's see it sometime this is the chat
so we'll see what happens Banco I don't
really play a critical line against the
bank oh I mean the acceptance awesome
considered to be very strong about that
but nowadays there are new ideas
so-called Peru know which variation and
black is scoring decently them
there's a question will i cover the
candidates tournament yes of course I
will I'm covering them I'm always
covering the big the big events so
candidates as well isn't that night of
seven year I try have I lost the game
yet in my new apartment yes today when I
recorded the video I wait to remember
that this is possible maybe I'm wrong
maybe you can take with the Queen Herod
queen takes
check hmm why did I play that anyway
let's let's see what happens here still
has some coordination issues hmm somehow
I feel like history repeating like I had
this stuff on the board earlier and it
didn't work out back then who do I
consider the play with the most talent
for chess one that doesn't need to work
hard but still play whatever had a hat
I'm possible to tell
there was some kind of nonsense but I
did I did do that taking 107 playing a
normal kind of game I was thinking that
this is working but probably not
the talk about tournaments as one one
suggestion to play the Danish extra
conscious open previously called the
poly chicken cup it's a very strong open
tournament yeah definitely as I have
considered to play that at some point
but I ultimately did not go for that
because I didn't quite like the setting
there it's outside Copenhagen but it's
like a couple of couple of miles it's a
little bit more than a couple of months
like one hour by train or by car to
Copenhagen and I really did not know if
I would join that tournament what I will
be doing they are the whole day ok so
the dead dead bishop has no square if
you want to go to Copenhagen this is
just a long time I can take here eyes at
night is so damn strong when you blunder
that piece but the night is strong hmm
how to do that says something better
than taking the night of the bishop
probably not
it's still not so easy a rookie 7 I
wonder if 23 is a move here I'm one porn
down which is interesting so just for
possible return of the material this is
what I'm let's go look at eight coming
now let's do this
hmm I how annoying I don't have a good
good things now to cover this I don't
want to play into f1 som I wrote you
have one
just kind of annoying
covering covering stuff maybe looking
aid or something no time morning's f4
would help but not quite sure if I can
get it in my I know i blundered rookie 7
yeah it's difficult to the nidus damn
strong it's just a damn strong piece
just didn't take it
check
edgy through the screen a form check I
get some better options but still not at
all easy playing for mate check let's
meet buddy look aged 7 checkmate wow
black resigns what a nice run I was very
lucky i was lucky really ok let's get in
just one more game and see if again get
her to 70 yeah someone says my comments
was part of the reason why someone
decided not to play last year what
tournament this meant what tournament is
referred to I don't know please tell me
did I say something negative about a
particular tournament I pretty cautious
with those kind of things they were only
mention if something that really sucks
ok well here I always thought that this
is kind of dangerous a white would see
they normally take on f6 in this
position so again the man what about
your bishop
why am I not winning a bishop here tell
me when I maybe get some kind of weird
compensation because my position is a
esas kind of Swiss cheese quality right
yeah yeah there are some some issues
here so I'm going to take that check and
check so what now King irate probably
not sure that looks like the relatively
safest so how to how to develop stuff 27
and I want to avoid to capture and give
them look f3e the sisters km I don't
don't I don't want to allow that this
looks sensible
night x 5 24 Bishop see 325 that looks
okay
yeah and no I think someone says
christie would be a bit higher rated
than I am on yes yes sure it would
probably be higher and someone says 300
points that that I actually think is
kind of impossible he won't be out on
2,700 something him that's too high he's
a very good blitz player if he really
gets when if he plays and this actor and
so on but 2700 I don't think so I mean
we can check he still has an account
here which he does not use because of
his affiliation was just 20 forward
still okay um go here bishop's six yeah
for that move i was a little bit afraid
of but is it so dangerous probably just
move the night but way I'm here maybe we
can check what green one who's this
rating was five minutes it was to 560
last rating at 26 65 was the highest
okay so look t32 here
let's sit co-create I guess Quincy one
is a is a threat now ya think the check
check then just scrapped you five
yeah he's threatening them Khun age
eight now still slightly murky but he
doesn't really have enough pieces in
play just go Bishop c6 now ninety five
things like that so it's got a possible
check on before of it hmm yes it's kind
of it's in down it's part of the
position um maybe just this 45
yeah it's okay that's no big threats
I've got 119 left so so the time the
time could be could be the issue but
position wise there's not much left for
him to do also Quincy five now white
resigned yeah that's kind of kind of
understandable this not not much left so
this is the first ever session that I've
played here in this show why I went for
a whitewash seven wins no losses no
draws with some luck here and there but
also I think I played quite quite
decently yeah I hope you enjoyed the
show it was the first show after my man
moved to to the new apartment which I
told you a lot about in recent streams
that it was kind of stressful so I'm
really happy to have settled in and can
too yeah to be able to focus more about
on chest such as videos broadcast and so
on um yeah I'm hope you hope you liked
it I'll be back next week there will
also be a simultaneous display again in
march for the iso seem and maybe also
some live content on my own on my own
channel let's see what happens yeah i'm
leaving with a 100-percent score on this
monday 29s thanks guys bye bye